field to the players
the Skippers entered in style these
aren't Cricket captains but leaders of
the two Nations about to square off on
the field as they celebrate their
decades-long friendship much of this
record-breaking crowd in Ahmedabad has
come to catch the action off the pitch
this is a very special occasion Narendra
Modi stadium is the biggest one in the
world and Prime Ministers of both
countries playing in the Test match will
be present at the stadium I wish India
wins the match and qualifies for the
world test championship
the ground can hold more than 130 000
fans and was renamed the Narendra Modi
stadium in 2021 it's in the western
state of Gujarat where Modi was chief
minister the pitch has seen historic
cricketing Innings the life of prime
minister and also served as a political
arena in 2020 it hosted the mega Road
show of Modi and then U.S president
Donald Trump
the cricket diplomacy comes as India is
pushing for a greater International role
India is the president of G20 this year
it's a duty New Delhi takes seriously
seeing it as an opportunity to project
itself as the voice of the global South
particularly on issues affecting
developing nations like climate change
Food Supplies and high debt
India is already leading the format
series winning this final match will
secure a sport in the finals of the
world test Championship the opposition
is eager to deny this Victory obviously
the start of the series didn't go to
plan losing the first two games but you
know there's a lot in it for India as
well if they win they can secure a spot
and not have to rely on other results so
you know we want to make that difficult
as difficult as possible for them and we
want to end the series on a high
celebrating the first
the two nations are expected to
strengthen trade and diplomatic ties Al
Jazeera New Delhi